(instrumental music)
(monitor beeping)
- Doctor!
Doctor, get in here quick!
- [Doctor] Is
everything all right?
- The coma patient, sir.
He's woke.
- What?
No, he's not awake.
- No, no, no.
It's not that he's awake,
it's that he's woke.
See.
Even though he's asleep,
he's somehow aware of
all the social injustices
black people are
facing everyday.
That's why he's
wearing this sweet ass
Black Lives Matter shirt.
- Actually, all lives matter.
What, I'm a doctor.
I took an oath.
- Oh, wait a minute.
He's got a voting
ballot from 2014
and he wrote in Rachel Dolezal.
Aw, you know, he didn't know,
none of us knew back then.
(cellphone ringing)
Oh shit!
He's getting a call
from Erykah Badu.
This dude is woke as fuck.
- Wait, I don't understand.
How does he know
what's going on?
- Well, I'm glad you asked that.
It's not just about
(pensive music)
seeing and hearing.
Being woke is a feeling,
deep inside the human heart.
- He's right.
Injustice anywhere is a
threat to justice everywhere.
- Oh my God, you're awake!
And you you use to care
about such trivial shit!
But now,
you probably don't care
that Girls just ended.
- What!
Girls is ending?
You bastard!
(gasping)
(monitor flatlines)
- Why'd you have
to say that man?
Such a fucking morning.